so you've
talked about the concept of definitive
truth
what is it and in general what is the
nature of truth in human civilization
and just talking about the digital age
the nature of truth in the digital age
so the interesting thing about
definitive truth is that it actually
exists on um on this at least in my mind
on this spectrum
between objective truth and just you
know somebody uh made something up and
nobody else agrees
so what i what i think definitive truth
is is it somewhere in the middle on that
spectrum
where if you and me def define
uh what truth is right like if you and
me have an agreement of some kind
and we say as long as the weather
is sunny or the weather isn't there is
no rain on that day
then there will be an insurance policy
that results and you and me both agree
that as long as three sensors
three monitoring weather monitoring
stations all say that
then the definitive truth for us and for
that agreement
is the result of those systems
coming to consensus about what happened
out in the real world
i i think the objective um truth
definition
from from kind of the philosophical
world is really really
stringent and very very hard to attain
and that's not
that's not what this is and that's
actually not what commerce
or the ability for people to interact
about contracts needs
what i think the world of commerce needs
is an upgrade
from someone can unilaterally decide
what the truth is
two there can be a pre-agreed set
of conditions where we define what the
truth is
under those conditions and then you know
you and me basically say
if these 20 nodes or of these 30 data
sources
come to consensus within you know this
method of consensus with this threshold
of agreement
then definitive truth has been achieved
for you and me in in our relationship
for this specific agreement and the
specificity
and and our shared agreement to that
kind of truth or that definitive truth
being acceptable to both
both of us is is probably what's what's
um kind of necessary and sufficient for
everything to move forward in a better
way
in any case much better than you know
i'm a bank or an insurance company
i'm going to unilaterally decide what
happens it's it's definitely an upgrade
from that
do you think it's possible to define
formally in this way
a definitive truth for many things in
this world like you talked about whether
so basically defining that if three
sensors of weather agree
then we're going to agree that that is a
definitive
useful truth for us to operate under
so how many things in this world can be
formalized in this way do you think
uh a huge a huge amount so so there's
there's actually
um two two things going on here
one thing is the amount of data that
already exists right and the pieces of
data coming off of
you know markets iot shipment of goods
any any number of other things like even
even your youtube channel has a certain
amount of likes
or a certain amount of clicks or a
certain amount of views and even that's
quantifiable right so even
to a certain degree what we do here
today you and me right now
can be quantified as far as the amount
of views the amount of
clicks the amount of any number of
others you the viewer have power
of data in your hands by clicking like
or dislike right now
or the subscribe button or the
unsubscribe button which i encourage you
to do
anyway uh okay so there's data flowing
in into
all interactions in this world there's
data there's more and more data right
like
more data more and more data that data
is more and more accessible to everybody
and that accessibility and the fact that
there's more of it means we can form
more definitive truth
proofs we can form more and more proofs
and as we form those proofs
well we can provide them to these
blockchains and smart contract systems
that consume them
and then they're tamper proof right so
they can't be manipulated
and so now we've combined a system that
can prove things with a system that
guarantees us certain outcomes
and we have a better system of contracts
which is which is
actually an unbelievably powerful tool
that has never existed before
you